[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing sible
trolloni and her role as a seer
depending on how you look at it sybil
patricia trulorney is one of the finest
seers of her age
and she's actually the one who correctly
prophesies the fate that both harry
potter and lord voldemort would share
but even though she correctly defined
the destiny of the chosen one trolloni
seems to get a bad rap and it only takes
one quick glance at her to see why
with frizzled hair an ancient
dust-covered purse and glasses as thick
as coke bottles professor trelawny
doesn't really give the impression that
she's able to see much of anything
let alone the future
but you might be surprised to know that
this humble divination professor from
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
correctly foresaw dozens of predictions
and prophecies
and today we're going to take a look at
the majority of them
when we take a deep dive into professor
trolone's life it's hard to look past
the very first true prophecy she made
while sitting alongside albus dumbledore
in aberforth's hog's head in troulony
foresaw the future and the fate of lord
voldemort the prophecy reads the one
with the power to vanquish the dark lord
approaches
born to those who have thrice to find
him born as the seventh month dies and
the dark lord will mark him as his equal
but he will have power the dark lord
knows not
and either must die at the hand of the
other for neither can live while the
other survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord will be born as
the seventh month dies
to most this was an obvious premonition
about harry potter and tom riddle
born in july 1980 harry potter was the
one with the power to vanquish the dark
lord and once lord voldemort heard about
it he wasted no time he frantically
journeyed to the potter's residence
aimed his wand at harry and cast a spell
to end the infant's life
but it backfired
in later years dumbledore would remark
that it was voldemort's own actions his
own killing curse that was his undoing
and that if the dark lord had done
nothing at all perhaps the prophecy
wouldn't have come true
as harry grew and eventually enrolled in
hogwarts this prophecy fell under
further scrutiny as there was another
child born in the seventh month of that
year
neville longbottom
he too could have been the one to end
voldemort's life as he fit the
requirements that trelawney's prophecy
laid out but while reflecting on the
possibility of neville being the chosen
one dumbledore only said that
voldemort's own actions decided the
prophecy
and in the end voldemort decided to
attack harry which meant harry would be
the one to fulfill the prophecy
after that meeting in hogsmeade early in
1980 trelawny went on to work full-time
at hogwarts
during her time there the students all
marveled at her ability to seemingly
fail at predicting the future
and perceiving things in general but in
1994 she made another striking prophecy
in the midst of a class trelloni's body
was consumed by a wave of visions and
her voice transformed almost as if it
was someone else's entirely
as a vessel for the future trelloni
loudly proclaimed what she saw to the
gathering of third year students it will
happen tonight the dark lord lies alone
and friendless abandoned by his
followers
his servant has been chained these
twelve years
tonight before midnight the servant will
break free and set out to rejoin his
master
the dark lord will rise again with his
servant's aid
greater and more terrible than he ever
was
tonight before midnight the servant will
set out to rejoin
his master
this of course was about the former
member of the order of the phoenix and
secret death eater peter pettigrew
not long after trolone's frightening
vision peter pettigrew stopped hiding in
the form of ron weasley's pet scabbers
and revealed who he truly was
now when we take a fine tooth to comb
through the rest of professor trelawny's
divinations of the future
it's hard to find much of consequence
even albus dumbledore seemed to
regularly enjoy teasing trolloni and
even poked fun of her abilities when
discussing her with harry and other
students
besides her great prophecy about harry
and voldemort and her second one
regarding peter pettigrew professor
trelawny's later visions weren't too
remarkable or at least not seriously
considered
but they were accurate during class she
was especially insightful when it came
to neville longbottom at several points
in time she was able to correctly
predict what the gryffindor boy would do
next like breaking a cup or arriving
late to class
although this might have been just
common sense considering how clumsily
neville seemed to navigate life in
hogwarts it might have also been
evidence of her divination powers
but professor trelawny didn't limit her
predictions to mild observations she was
also able to predict the love lives of
her students
once when she saw the future of a young
gryffindor girl named parvati patil she
warned the student about a man with red
hair
patil waited and waited and as the days
turned to weeks and the weeks turned to
months patil must have thought it was
another wild raving that trelawny had
become known for
but after a few years ron weasley ended
up dating patil's best friend one date
anyway which caused a rift between the
two
to those that discredit professor
trelawney's gifts of divination this
prediction might seem pretty bizarre
after all if parvati patil waited her
whole life for a random redhead man to
do something upsetting then she surely
would have experienced something to
justify trelawney's prophecy
at some point in the future if a redhead
man said a rude remark or accidentally
shut a door in her face
could patil point to that and claim it
was evidence of trolloni's powers of
foresight
this type of criticism that trollone's
visions were so broad that they were
inevitably right is hard to contend with
but we simply have to look back at her
two most powerful prophecies and we can
see that surely trulani possessed some
gift for seeing the future at various
other times events unfolded within
hogwarts that seemed to add more and
more evidence to trelloni's claim that
she could see the future
once the same girl that ron would date
received a notice that her pet hair had
died
trelawny predicted that lavender would
receive bad news on that very day
and her pet's death seems to make it
true
at some point trolloni claimed that a
member of their class would be leaving
them forever
many of the students thought this meant
that someone would move or worse that
they would die
but later in the year hermione simply
unenrolled in the course it was a far
less dramatic turn of events than
trelawney had made it seem
but it came true nonetheless
but the consequences of these unofficial
prophecies weren't always so shallow
at one point while eating lunch on
christmas day professor trelawny looked
at her fellow staff members and declared
that the first teacher to stand up would
also be the first one to die
that came true as albers dumbledore
eventually rose from the table and he
would give his life in a ruse to trick
the dark lord voldemort and when the new
headmistress dolores umbridge took over
hogwarts professor trelawny made another
ambiguous but grim prediction
she claimed that umbridge's future was
dark which really wasn't all that
interesting
given how remarkably broad trelloni's
prophesizing skills seemed to be
umbridge decided to remove her from her
position as divination professor
but in later years umbridge's fate
imprisoned amongst the centaurs and
later in the cells of azkaban seemed to
redeem trelawny sometime later shortly
before dumbledore's death trelloni
sensed the headmaster's doom yet again
her mind was plagued with images of a
tall tower and a bolt of lightning
on the night of his death dumbledore was
struck with the green bolt of the
killing curse which matched trelawney's
prediction entirely while the exact time
and location was likely to move
dumbledore himself would eventually ask
snape to kill him to further their cause
and help bring them one step closer to
defeating voldemort when we look back at
the life and predictions of professor
trelawny it's certainly tough to make
sense of it all
just like her critics you might be
tempted to point to all the wild claims
the diviner has made through the years
and used that as evidence of her lack of
skills
and i'm not sure many people would blame
you for it
if it weren't for her otherworldly
premonition while sitting with albus
dumbledore and hogsmeade nobody in the
wizarding world would have ever taken
her seriously but even though that
prophecy and a few others would
eventually come true trelloni's own
penchant for ambiguous visions and
seemingly flat out wrong predictions
would always stain her reputation and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you